check your mics
[Music]
i think i'm good
okay
hello listeners welcome to another week
of the pillpods featuring me eric tate
and
we are down one pod member today however
uh due to scheduling conflicts uh master
pills will not be with us just the
slaves
exactly so uh
but we do have the uh distinct pleasure
of having a guest of the show uh and a
good friend
returning to us today uh this is
victor hain as you know to you folks as
lit vic if you've listened to the
previous episodes he's been on how are
you doing victor i'm doing great guys
good to be back great to have another
literature corner
great to have another victor on always a
party with the victors always a party
with two victors and of course we have
politics victor victor b and matthew how
are you guys doing hello not bad not bad
busy week but it's been fun it was fun
to revisit this um yeah and let's read
the story again it's been a while yeah
great stuff yeah we have something
prepared to you today uh for
listening to uh that was a really good
sentence uh so
we're doing
the
edgar allan poe short story today called
the purloined letter
so it's a short story by poe written
around 1845 i believe a story featuring
a detective named august dupain now
before we get into the story however i
think it'd be good to talk about why we
chose
to
read a short story um
you know we did our episode on bartleby
and we really enjoyed it and i think you
listeners responded quite well to uh a
kind of literature corner episode
yeah yeah and i think i think it's also
just uh i mean obviously with bartleby
there's a lot of our favorite
philosophers who talk about bart will be
right jay jack talks about bartleby
we did that episode on beyond chulhang
he talks about bartleby it doesn't deliz
talk about bartleby so there's like a
lot of philosophical reasons and then
similarly now with purloined letter
lacan has a pretty famous essay where he
tries to show how the purloin letter can
which we'll get into maybe later
just as a demonstration of kind of the
way the unconscious is structured like a
language is structured by symbols and
there's a kind of automatic effect and
somehow he uses the prolonged letter to
uh and i guess i i only learned
uh from like revisiting this that
daredevil has a response essay which we
didn't read but maybe if people like
this episode we can do like a patron
episode or something and and and explore
the dareda uh thing but uh yeah kind of
literature fight night fighting over
literature philosophy literature fight
night exactly yeah that's right as this
is a critical theory and philosophy
podcast we uh also like to take in
literature because it's a
major stimulant to the development of
philosophy and critical theory and
psychoanalysis and all that good stuff
uh where were you gonna say matt i was
gonna say speaking of stimulants on the
other end of the prestige spectrum i
like andrew allen poe because he is
proof uh that having serious substance
abuse problems and [ __ ] your cousin
can take you very very far in life uh so
imagine what you always wanted uh and
secondly i want to ask on the other end
of the prestige spectrum uh how many of
you you was your first encounter with
poe that simpsons episode uh where homer
is you know reciting oh no what is it uh
homer's in the raven yeah but i think
it's
what's the name the raven was definitely
my first encounter bart is the raven
yeah as always it all goes back to the
simpsons yeah i think i've actually used
that episode when teaching the ravens so
it's it's a touchstone never more never
but uh
why don't you give us a little like
historical context or background on poe
and like where is this story sort of
situated within his
larger ubra if you will yeah definitely
i mean one of the other reasons perhaps
we're looking at it now is it was
actually poe's birthday last week uh
january 19th i believe yeah
so uh
what's the most melancholy drink that we
can think of uh
maybe absent
yeah let's let's raise the glass first
of all yeah to the app to the absence of
some cafe something with opium in it
probably yeah yeah good 19th century
style yeah i've got a beer here in front
of me i haven't had a beer in a while
oh yeah cheers yeah so because yeah
poe's reputation definitely precedes him
like we all know as the famously
turbulent melancholy kind of gothic
writer um
and among other things he he also had
gambling debts he changed his name to
avoid his creditors he was edgar a perry
for a while
does that still work it worked in the
1800s yeah
so
just shaves his mustache off and people
are like well i'm looking for mr edgar
allen paul it's like no no this is edgar
perry yeah if you've ever seen a picture
of this guy it's hard to imagine him
being disguised and unable to recognize
him he's got a very distinctive face and
i always imagine there's like ravens or
something circling around
you are right though i mean i went
through a bit of a po phase years and
years ago around when i was 18 like
everyone did and i liked a lot of the
short stories i never got around to this
one and what was surprising about it is
it really doesn't have a very poesque
feel you know it's a pretty
straightforward um it's very much
detective story but there's none of that
gothic melodrama uh nobody even dies in
it which is kind of yeah what's the deal
what's the deal with that ludvik what's
the story with this yeah being very
melancholy well most of his stories they
do deal with the macabre the alienation
of modern society and i think the
the way this story kind of comes into
his uber is that it still sort of
focuses on questions of urbanization and
modernization right so
poe is actually credited with inventing
the genre of detective fiction
so he was always interested in short
stories and poems like that he kind of
believed that any sort of work of art
should be able to be consumed in just
one sitting
and that was what sort of drove his
interest in short stories for unity of
effect but then we get to detective
fiction which kind of comes from his
broader interest in things like
cryptography like code breaking and this
sort of question of what it was called
um
radio cenation so like tales of
reasoning as it was known back then
tales of kind of like deductive
reasoning
and
this was sort of like his actually his
second story i believe with the
character of auguste dupont who's this
sort of french genius who solves these
cases and this was decades before even
like sherlock holmes or any other kind
of like famous detectives so
poe was really kind of a pioneer in
terms of this sort of short story and
this kind of character but
one of the interesting things like one
of the reasons why this story does sort
of stand out compared to his broader
work is that as you noted it's actually
not very sensational it's very kind of
like cool analytical
almost detached in the way that it
presents the facts of the case
and then sort of just walks us through
it and we sort of see how the detective
solves the mystery of the purloined
letter yeah so if you haven't read it
listeners i would recommend even just
pausing and going taking a look at it
it'll take you just an hour to get
through it it's quite short and it's uh
it's really interesting sorry what were
you going to say matt no yeah i should
say i really enjoyed this it was a lot
of fun
and it was a lot of fun in the same way
that i used to like reading sherlock
holmes stars this is actually a question
we were debating before you got here
litvic
do you know if arthur conan doyle
ever read edgar allen poe i'm sure there
was a kind of cross-pollination
influence because this really did feel
like a sherlock holmes story to me
except for the kind of big long
metaphysical or epistemological
interlude which we can get to
because you know there's this kind of
bumbling lestrade like figure who can't
solve this case it seems extremely
mysterious he comes in and he's like you
sort this out for me and of course dupe
makes it all look so easy and he's
really cool and he pulls the letter out
and he's like here you go
and then they're like how did you do it
and it gives this extremely elaborate
explanation to it and it really did
remind me of a lot of sherlock holmes
and this watson like narrator we get too
very similar to uh yeah to the yeah it
really later i mean that in a good way
because i like both of them so
definitely it definitely like lays out a
lot of the tropes of detective fiction i
think conan doyle actually credited
poe's dupont as an inspiration directly
for sherlock holmes yeah so there was a
recognition of this kind of being the
first model for these sorts of stories
even i think dostoyevsky in crime and
punishment he kind of acknowledged that
porfiry petrovic in that story the
investigator was modeled on dupont so
this guy's sort of like the godfather
for all detectives in the 19th century
yeah i guess i'm dating myself by saying
uh i yeah i've probably first
encountered poe on the simpsons uh yeah
[ __ ] you i was born in the 80s what are
you going to do about it uh but another
place that really got me seriously
interested in poe was probably reading
nabakov's lolita and the uh
the central place that one poem in
particular the annabel lee poem takes in
that in that novel as well really sort
of
rekindled slash made even bigger my
interest in paul but i think another
really interesting sort of
note
side note is that poe was very popular
in france from very early on i believe
i'm not sure i believe
charles baudelaire translated this story
and maybe others into french quite early
which is the reason why um
you know i think it leads into why you
know lacan was writing about it why
derrida responded why it was so
important that you know these
philosophers and analysts would thought
that this was material they should be
writing about it's because he was very
very popular a lot of his stories are
set in paris but they're also translated
into french and red in in france so he's
very very popular there or quite early
on and
i'm not sure why that happened uh i
imagine
it links back to what vic was saying
about this sort of exploring the sort of
macabre and the dark the interiority and
urbanization baudelaire was a real uh
sort of you know what we call them
flanners right those guys who love to
walk around the city and
observe and
let their whimsy take them where it will
yeah and more broadly as well sorry matt
it's perhaps also poe is himself deeply
influenced by european romanticism but
in this case especially he kind of has
this idealized french european genius
in the character of august dupont so in
some ways like i think the french were
quite pleased with reading a story like
this in particular
there is something that's
kind of classy or romantic about setting
it in paris uh where he talks about
these kind of guilded hotels the fact
that there's these extremely wealthy
people who want this letter found uh
that the political balance of nations
kind of hangs
on the scandal that might be unleashed
at the letters at least so i don't know
if you could get that setting it in a
town in new england you know population
you know 500 circa you know 1835 or
whatever right there needs to be some
kind of gravity to add to the drama of
it but i think it really works right
there's this almost dashing uh quality
and actually on on the details of the
story i mean maybe maybe it's one of us
i don't know lit vik i'm looking at you
can give a little plot summary of like
what what are the main things that
happen here before we for sure start
talking about too many specifics yeah so
one of the reasons why it is a little
bit more glamorous is because the
queen's letter from her lover or some
mysterious person has actually been
stolen purloined by a minister
who is also in the government and so the
police are kind of bumbling around
trying to figure this out as they do in
detective fiction and the local
constabulary hasn't had much success
even though they've kind of searched the
premises of this minister's house
they've searched every square inch of
the neighboring houses there's this sort
of there's been this very precise
mathematical search of every sort of air
area around there and they kind of
relate the details of this case to
august dupont and to the narrator
and dupont and the audience listens to
the facts of the case
and then about a week later or so or a
month later
the police shows up again and dupont
asked them simply do you want me to give
you the letter because i've already
found it so he solved the case without
even trying basically
right that's the very sherlock holmes
anticipating sherlock holmes like kind
of uh yeah impressive uh
i i should say unlike sherlock though
he does do this for a quite hefty sum of
money i think it's like yeah give him
give him that detail yeah yeah i mean
sherlock holmes would sometimes just do
it to kind of show is that
all right let's ride i'll do this for
you but in return you get to sit there
and marvel at my genius for at least
five minutes as i explain to you how i
unleash my deductive powers oh yeah
japan seems a little bit you know i want
to do that but i also want you know a
fat paycheck at the end of this
right so in terms of the narrative right
it's it's everything's already happened
the events have passed and they're being
sort of recounted by this unnamed
narrator and friend of dupont's he's
also in the story
and then even the dialogue he's
reporting
happens you know after the theft of the
letter right it's it's been something
like 18 months and this guy's been
basically blackmailing the the queen of
france um with his possession of this
letter to get you know he has power over
her with this that's the that's the
problem right and it has to be dealt
with sensitively because
the contents of this letter would damage
the honor and legitimacy of the queen
which we don't know by the way we don't
we never find out the contents of the
letter but litvik what so what happens
how did how did dupan find the letter
what's his yeah trick what's his magic
well that's a great point as well eric
because it is like again almost like
this abstract narrative where everything
is being like described and nothing we
don't actually see things directly
there's not a lot of action to begin
with anyway but we do have this
intellectual distance from the events as
you noted which is very important and we
also don't know what the letters
contents actually contain except that it
is a sensitive piece of information that
the queen desperately wants to have
returned to her yeah so then dupont
basically reveals to the narrator
who's kind of like an audience surrogate
at this point that he sort of went
through the thought process of the
criminal's own mindset he kind of tried
to identify with this minister who had
stolen the letter and thought about how
he would have tried to outwit the police
and what he ultimately figures out quite
easily for him because his this
brilliant sleuth is that the police's
approach was completely misguided like
they basically made a category mistake
by even trying to look for the letter in
hidden places
because he knows that this minister who
stole the letter was he was both a
mathematician but he was also a poet as
you know so he had this sort of balance
in terms of thinking more creatively
outside the box than what the police
might have been expecting him to do so
long story short what's the best place
to hide a letter
it's on the on the mantelpiece right so
it's that oh classic cliche if you don't
want someone to find something hide it
in plain sight
so do hidden in plain dupont reveals how
he visited this minister's house he got
he got him to look outside at one point
on the street with some distraction and
he noticed that the letter was on the
mantelpiece basically it was hiding
there in plain sight the whole time
and he comes back the next day he swaps
the letter with a forgery
and so he he's accomplished his
brilliant feat of both reclaiming the
letter
and not even telling the minister that
like the letter is missing because the
minister still thinks that the letter's
there it's been swapped
and it was all basically because he
recognized like the police's approach
was completely misguided in this case
they didn't understand the criminal
mindset sufficiently and that's what
opens up all the interesting
interpretive questions about what were
the police doing wrong and what does
dupont understand in this case that made
it right yeah
there's one report that i think we
should emphasize just at the conclusion
because it turns out that dupont and the
minister were enemies yes uh they had to
run in before and there was almost kind
of a mariarty feel to it which i
appreciated also because uh dupay was
like he outwitted me once uh so now just
to kind of do a little something for
myself in this forged letter i left a
little message for him uh and then he
refers uh to
two greek brothers who betrayed one
another frequently and it ends with one
of the brothers atreus serving the
others sons up to him as a meal without
him knowing and he's like if this
revenge isn't good enough for the one
it's really good enough for the other uh
and i thought that was a nice little
touch to end on
about the only thing that i was a little
sad about when it came to the plot and
this is just a kind of a pulpy point is
i like these kind of rivalries you know
you think moriarty and sherlock and i
almost kind of want to see the villain
play a more active role as some kind of
sinister being there it is you're you're
a super hero like story mindset
a little bit more action look at that i
wanted a little more action yeah that's
the first superhero
i i will say that it was offset for me
by this really extraordinary dialogue in
the middle of it that we can come back
to because i don't want to go there yet
um but yeah i did definitely want
something that was a little bit more
like gotcha a little spicier but that is
a lot of shade that he throws at the end
yeah that quote from greek myth about
how basically you know atria served up
theiste's brothers to him at a feast or
something like there's a hint that the
rivalry between these two men ran a
little bit deeper than just this case
yeah between dupont and this mysterious
minister yeah yeah if you if you've
dipped into uh the greek lore you know
that the house of is it the house of
atrius yeah the house of atreus not
atreides i think that's dune the house
of atrius is um
family yeah the atreides are their
children so that's right yeah there's
some def there's some word borrowing
there so not we're not talking about
dune here we're talking about greek myth
yeah the
the house of atrius is a storied story i
think i think they estee's originally um
did something to
i this here's the french word declay
atreus he did something to him involving
um was it seducing his wife or his or
her he slept with his wife and then
atreus murders his sons yeah and
atreus's children were actually
agamemnon and menelaus so the the story
doesn't end there's there spiny stretch
yeah so the the implication i guess
being that the uh the minister is
thyestes with his uh first offense that
was you know pretty bad but but then you
know here's this here's uh dupan being
atria serving him up his uh the blood of
his children or something which is the
sort of ultimate revenge and
that's what he's referring to in this in
this little uh note he leaves in uh the
fake letter which he replaced with the
real one and that that's actually a key
point but we circle back to the
the fact that um
he still thinks he has the queen's
letter when he doesn't really
i would like to say though but i do
think this is a nice kind of little
mirroring of their rivalry also because
dupe clearly has a bit of respect for
the minister and like you said victor uh
it's heavily important which one
literally
get it right okay jesus i try my best to
be precise um it's kind of heavily
implied that there's a rivalry that goes
a bit deeper uh than just this issue uh
but he oda also comes across as somebody
who does have the mind not just of a
mathematician uh but a poet and the kind
of proof of that is of course uh he
leaves this little poetic rejoinder to
his rival at the end it's not enough
just to kind of
figure out the puzzle uh that was left
for him uh there also has to be an
element of art to it
so i appreciated that i thought it did a
nice job of kind of mirroring the two
personalities of our protagonist
antagonists in a really economical way
for sure yeah if they're not directly
meant to be kind of like brothers there
is this sense of them almost being
doubles in that way yeah that you kind
of have to become
in some ways you have to share elements
of the criminal mind in order to even
solve a case like this yeah so that's
what dupont seems to kind of
pull off in the end
yeah you know i will say that one of the
things i found uh
like reading the story is the detectives
like disc don't they describe this like
super mathematical process where they
like they like used like uh
like some kind of geometry method where
they like measured out the whole
apartment and like went like literally
like inch by inch like square by square
maybe it was triangles i forget exactly
what it was but they use some method
i guess i just didn't i just don't
believe that they wouldn't have found it
it's excruciating i was just like that
is just not believable to me like if
they literally did this triangular
method and like and like sketched traced
the whole apartment or whatever and
didn't find it
this is an anecdote from my life but my
brother was just being an [ __ ] i
guess
but my brother was looking for
his homework once
and because i was his older brother i
actually hid it on the table and he
scoured the whole house for a day
getting really angry being like where's
my homework i need my homework and i
need to study and i literally was
sitting right in front of it and he
asked me he was like i don't know like
and i was like i don't know i don't know
and then i finally gave it to him so
that can happen maybe my brother's a
really really smart guy it's just i
agree it can it can happen but i guess i
yeah i mean i'm just being nitpicky here
obviously i'm just saying that i
remember thinking like okay so you used
this like method and traced every single
surface in the apartment but didn't see
it but that's that's the point actually
it's like it's the absurdity of the
method right it's so exaggerated it's so
fantastical they're like opening every
book checking every page they look in
the garden like between every brick like
the moss and everything so it's almost
like it becomes like half cask or like
something kind of like a borges like
short story about labyrinths or
libraries like the point of it is almost
to prove that like they were so off base
like they they had the best technology
in the world they had like forensic
equipment whatever
but because they couldn't identify with
the criminal they were never gonna find
the letter because the tools they were
using for the job were not the right
tools
right right so i think i think isn't it
i mean i i take the point that you know
you know you can imagine that they're
looking and they're obsessed with a
hiding space right like they're they're
obsessed with like this idea that it's
going to be somewhere really hidden so
you know it's true that they're using
this method and then they're really just
looking at
a place for it to be hidden rather than
like a surface so like yeah i mean i
grant that it's it's it's definitely and
we've all obviously i think also
it's just kind of stimulating or kind of
like working off of all of our own
intuitions and our own experiences right
where we've had you know if we wear
glasses right you for you forget that
they're actually like above on top of
your head or whatever like we've all had
that experience where literally the
thing that we're looking for is like
right there so it's definitely playing
on that like very universal human
experience i suppose oh yeah that's
actually that's something i'd like to
drill down in into the narrative uh
before while we're still working on the
vanilla level here and we haven't
brought in any uh lacon
um so
yeah that's a good a great point is that
yes if the if they were using such a
thorough method to search the apartment
surely they would have gone through the
miscellaneous
letters and trash and things that like
the the letter was supposedly hidden
on a uh letter rack above like a
fireplace or something somewhere you'd
expect to find letters and somewhere
that you would then ipso facto not
expect anyone to be hiding a letter
right so this hidden in plain sight is
is a big motif in the story but it's
it's it starts right because the the
first time this
theft is described when when the uh when
the um prefect
describes the theft for the first time
he says the what happens is that the um
was it the queen has this letter
and uh and she's i guess she's she's
read it and she's about to sort of hide
it away when the king i guess some guy
who's
implicitly it's the king who walks in
first and she has no time to do anything
but to turn the letter over and just
sort of put it on the table as if it's
just a normal letter not something she
was going to hide and then of course the
king's not interested in it they go and
talk and then what happens next is this
other guy walks in the minister
who's only really named d minister d
walks in and immediately
um i guess he sees that the queen is
anxious about this letter
and that the king hasn't spotted it and
so what he does is he goes over with his
own letter he happens to be sort of uh
holding at the time goes about his
business in the royal apartments um
puts the letter down next to the queen's
letter
uh does some more talking you know
nonchalance nonchalance and then goes
back at the end picks up the queen's
letter and leaves the other letter in
its place hidden in
plain sight but it's no longer the
letter because he's stolen it and he
brings it to his own apartment and then
he proceeds to hide the letter in plain
sight as he knows the police procedures
he knows they'll be coming after him he
even leaves his apartment every night to
sort of make it easier for the police to
investigate right
and they of course they can't find it
and then dupe
sort of defining all of this
as the story is being told
uh goes himself and gets the letter by
disguising himself as somebody who is
maybe short-sighted with some glasses on
so he's able to look around the
apartment he sees like a crumpled up
letter and the letterbox knows
immediately that that's what he's
looking for because it's not hidden it's
out in the open
and he uh what he does is he he leaves
his snuff box pretend fake leaves his
snuff box behind and leaves
and then you know meanwhile at home he
makes a fact similarly of the letter
next day comes a call and again says oh
i forgot my snuff box gets let in they
have another conversation
he's paid somebody to create a
distraction outside so there's a gunshot
minister runs over to the window check
out what's going on out there and in the
kerfuffle uh dupant secretly then swaps
the uh queen's letter out
for this forgery now that he's replaced
it with and then proceeds to leave
and he keeps the letter in his apartment
and doesn't really give it back to the
police right away kind of uh
kind of waits for the police to come
back to him waits for the prefect to
come back to him and then he says that
uh get as soon as the policeman says uh
you know i'd pay my entire month years
wage for this letter because the reward
is so high he says ah well if that's the
case then here it is get your checkbook
out and here you go and so he sort of
almost
semi-dupes the the prefect into paying
him 50 000 francs or whatever it is and
then
goes on his way so this this motif of
being
hidden in plain sight is kind of
determined right from the beginning when
the queen sort of has no choice but to
just sort of leave it face down on the
table right and then
lo and behold the sort of
the that strategy is apparently exactly
what needs to be done to avoid the
police so
you know the the
minister d does the same thing i also
think it really adds the comic effect of
them employing these mathematical
techniques to try to discover where this
letter is to kind of obtain new
knowledge if you want because the kind
of irony is that they always knew where
the letter was
because it was hidden in plain sight
they walked by it a million times
and so all the kind of
mechanisms and efforts that they
undertook to discover it uh were pretty
useless and it has this real
deflationary effect uh when it comes to
our appreciation for these methods that
i thought was pretty funny in a lot of
ways and there is
kind of a lot of this in this story
where there's almost a rug being pulled
out of people's face like out of uh
under people's feet uh when they start
feeling
a little too grandiose about themselves
including you know the detective who
kind of sits there and i was like i'll
get forty thousand dollars for this
because the money is so great and then
he just handed the letter and he's kind
of like oh my god i feel like a fool but
whatever and then runs away in this kind
of bumbling manner yeah that's what's so
fascinating about this story actually is
that even though it was pretty much one
of the first detective sort of short
stories it already kind of starts to
subvert some of the tropes that it's
laying out because one of the big
appeals of detective fiction is kind of
you know listening to the detective
explain the case like a magician
revealing his trick right and the
audience perhaps having guest parts of
it but here it's actually a very simple
explanation it's not terribly convoluted
the letter was on the mantle piece
he just had to distract the guy and then
he took the letter and replaced it so
what is actually kind of perhaps being
probed here is not even so much the case
at a realistic level it's more the sort
of it's the thematic questions around
the case it's like why couldn't the
police find the letter what did they
lack which dupont has
and that's what kind of brings us back
to what you were talking about earlier
matt i think which is how dupont
understands the limits of the
mathematical mindset right or kind of
like this more positivist approach where
you're just sort of logically looking
around for where things should be
rather than looking at the bigger
picture
well this is a really this is what i
really want to discuss i'll come back in
two seconds after because like [ __ ] you
sorry
okay no no well like no i'm just kidding
go ahead the thing is
at one point in arthur conan doyle's
fiction uh watson actually makes a list
of what sherlock holmes seems to know
very much about right
very 19th century thing to do and he
lists all these scientific subjects uh
and of course his kind of logical powers
of deduction and he says sherlock is
really good in these areas but when it
comes to things like philosophy art and
it lists a bunch of other kind of uh
humanistic uh disciplines and interests
he says he knows next to nothing about
this
which is also echo that i should point
out in the benedict cumberbatch series
right where sherlock is very very
scientifically motivated knows nothing
about human beings
and yet what's interesting about dupe
uh is that
none of that skill set was necessary to
figure out this case right uh you almost
get the sense that if sherlock holmes
were put in there
he would fail at resolving it because
it's not clever uh in a certain sense
mechanical way what was really required
to understand where the letter was was
what the minister had and what dupe has
which is a kind of knowledge of human
motivations in particular the
motivations of the people who prefer who
pursue precisely these deductive
explanations to everything yeah that's a
good point
yeah and i think japan is also a
philosopher like he has a really
that you would never see from sherlock
right he has this really long
epistemological
discussion at the centerpiece of the
text that i can never imagine sherlock
holmes saying uh and he almost kind of
castigates people for approaching things
in this way it's really quite
interesting to me it's a that's a great
point but both of those last points were
good
because you know the payoff in a sort of
detective
fiction
it's like litvik was saying is that like
there's a payoff in the explanation at
the end how how the person gets caught
you know was it what was it was the dirt
on the fingernails it was the blood on
the uh it was the blood on the shoelace
or what whatever it was it it always
seems to imply that you know in case of
sherlock holmes he has some kind of
superhuman sensory capabilities it's
like everything in the room is
immediately registers in his mind and he
and he puts everything in his play he
has the superhuman abilities
he literally has a computer like brain
and just like this this this
yeah he's almost like like a fleshy data
who walks into every room and can just
immediately analyze everything
superhuman but in this case it's much
more psychological it has to do with
motives but also like litvik was saying
it almost it almost goes on to a
thematic almost
epistemological level
in that this difference between
the mathematician and the poet or the
sort of
what is just so blazingly obvious that
you can't see it versus you know
where do people go to look for things
that are hidden they go to they go to
the details right like that little
game example he gives with the maps
right you can you can play the map game
you know you play with two friends and
you you get them to you say the name of
a city or the name of something on the
map and whoever finds it first wins and
the way you can always fool the amateur
is if you just say
one of those words that's you know pr
printed broadly across the map like
something naming the continent or
something
and and it'll fool the amateur because
then they'll immediately go and look at
all the little cities and assume you've
chosen some little obscure thing and
then they won't see you know terra nova
or whatever the big sort of
semi-transparent word is that's printed
across the map so the mathematical mind
always goes to the details divides up
the space looks at every single last
inch whereas this sort of poetic mind
works a little bit differently the
poetic mind
almost works as like a bluffer you put
yourself in the position of the other
person and try to divine
their thought process
it's it's it reminds me a little bit of
what he says in the room org right in
the murders of the room org poe's other
story with dupe
that um you know chess requires
concentration whereas something like i
forget the other one checkers or poker
requires bluffing because everyone has
generally the same pieces generally the
same moves to make there's less rules so
it requires bluffing you have to know
how to psych out your opponent or get in
their head right as opposed to chess
which is very sort of
computational you just have to remain
focused and play the best hand possible
play the best strategy and perhaps to
build on that just a little bit yeah
what what it provides on top of bluffing
is also this question of empathy right
that's the that's what poetry and
literature more generally provides which
the mathematical spectrum and the
spectrum wouldn't it's this question of
identifying with the other person which
art would allow us to do and that is
where poetry comes in here that's
ultimately why dupont is able to think
like his nemesis here and solve the case
when the police are just kind of looking
at it like an equation or a puzzle to be
sorted out
what's the significance of that you're
not going to cut me off again no no no
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah you get it
yeah no uh i i just i was just gonna say
like there's also the significance of
that odds and evens game right like
where where he's talking about um
in the story isn't it isn't there like
an odds and evens game right where he's
saying like you know he goes through
this whole rumination of like you know
if i if if he picks odds the first time
and then i saw that he did and it's like
if he's really clever then maybe he
would pick it again and he like goes
like you know i don't know how many
layers deep in he goes like four layers
deep he's like but if he knows that i
know
that i think that he's gonna pick odds
then the clever thing would be to pick
evens or whatever and it's like this
whole thing that i don't know it was it
was interesting and i think la khan ends
up eventually running with that somehow
yeah you can definitely tell that poe
was a gambler as well just from the way
he talks about that like he's really
like thinking like three steps ahead of
his opponent yeah absolutely
yeah it's like a game odds and evens
yeah yeah it's like goes back to that
you know
going pla remember playing i don't know
rock paper scissors or something like
that back in the day right
you you try to fool your opponent so the
first time
you choose rock they beat you with paper
like so if you have a sort of simplistic
opponent which is always the assumption
of the police right the mathematical
mind is going to use the average they're
going to use the thing that works in the
most cases
so if you have your sort of average
opponent
you can assume that
you know if you play say next time you
choose
scissors there and they choose rock then
that establishes a pattern they say well
i'm not going to choose you know i'm not
going to choose this one again i'm going
to choose the next one it's a little
easier with odds and evens because
there's only two options so if you you
know i go odds and then next i go evens
your opponent thinks oh i see the
pattern here and then they're going to
follow that you just have to double
bluff them at that point but with a
sneakier opponent like the minister
who's also a poet and a mathematician
uh they're going to do something a
little more unexpected and so you need a
method
that is not
you know working
in the most cases for the average person
in the and looking for the most like
sort of dependable outcome you have to
choose a method where i mean in this
case it's going to be you know looking
for the obvious seeing what's right
under your nose
but the poet is going to be able to
empathize
with whoever
you know is opposing them or whoever
they're trying to
entertain or whatever they're going to
sympathize or empathize with them and be
able to sort of
divine their next move and and you know
fool that mathematical kind of
calculative approach
yeah you know what this reminds me of uh
as an antecedent in that respect it
might even be less something like
sherlock holmes which i think is the
more simplistic uh kind of genealogy
could draw it might be a little bit more
thing like a thomas harris novel uh you
know silence the lambs or red dragon uh
because will graham if you've seen the
show it's also really good uh you know
hannibal uh his super power to use
victor's kind of term uh is this kind of
capacity for almost radical empathy uh
even with extremely bad people in that
he can situate himself into their world
view and kind of understand their
motivation for doing certain things and
that's what allows him to solve a lot of
these crimes
not the fact that he kind of goes
through them in some very analytically
methodical way and in some senses
he's actually a lot quicker at resolving
these things precisely because he can do
this than the people who take the more
traditional approaches and i think
there's one other thing that we should
note which is that
it was actually necessary for the
minister to do this in these
circumstances because he was aware that
the queen has that or behest just vast
numbers uh of detectives who are going
to be applying this method uh so no
matter how clever he tried to hide it in
this traditional sense one way or
another they were going to find it they
would tear the house down brick by brick
so it was precisely by thinking outside
of the box uh that he was able to get
away with this for such a long time so
there was kind of a materialist
dimension to this also but i'm not sure
if you think that way because like
it seems to be almost like this is a
kind of psychological thriller
as much as being a detective story in
that sense right you really have to kind
of get in these people's head space all
good detective stories are going to be
somewhat psychological no
sure but i mean again sherlock holmes
deal with motivations
dealing with the most common denominator
types of behavior it's just worth
briefly noting as well that at this
particular stage in like the 1840s even
the notion of this kind of crime was
somewhat novel because
modern crime didn't really exist before
modern cities right and urbanization had
just kind of picked up from like you
know the late 1700s on this scale of
like the really big modern cities like
even like a paris or like a new york or
philadelphia in the states so that's why
there was this fascination with the
criminal mind is because like these were
really the first generations when you
even had this kind of like you know the
need for detectives the need for this
kind of you know investigation the term
detective hadn't even been coined yet
when poe wrote this story so a lot of
this which seems actually quite modern
to us was really like fresh and novel to
the audience that that poe was writing
to that's interesting but i want to ask
what's the difference then between this
poetic and mathematical intelligence
because
he really criticizes like [ __ ] is
just scathing uh towards this
mathematical intelligence not because
it's bad but because it's limited
and he says that a lot of people who
employ it have such confidence in their
abilities that they extend this kind of
method to absolutely everything even
where inappropriate which kind of
reminded me of the stephen pinker's of
the world interesting yes yes there's an
idw uh connection uh for our listeners
if you like politics stuff but then he
never really says like this is what the
kind of poetic mindset uh or poetic
approach entails uh he just gives
examples of it and maybe that in itself
is telling because it's not a method
that you can apply in the same kind of
rigorous way uh that you would
logical kind of deductions uh or even
kind of empirical inferences uh you have
to have a kind of visceral sense for
these things yeah i don't know if that
makes
that's actually i was almost reminded of
you know the the friendly rivalry
between analytical and continental
traditions where you can maybe see why
lacan liked the story where you know the
analytical mindset can only go so far
but you have to have you know the
continental the more open-minded
approach in some cases to actually solve
these kinds of cases to interpret these
kinds of texts so that might be an
interesting way to kind of transition to
the the con seminar as well on the story
yeah no i think we should i think we
should we should start considering what
uh
what is lacan up to i guess in in this
seminar uh i don't know if anyone wants
to take an initial stab that's good um
yeah i just preface it by um
by
saying you know we like what them what
does this story mean you know what do we
do with it how do we interpret it we
we've obviously been offering sort of
interpretations along the way here and
and talking about the context and and
doing
some close reading of the text and
looking at some of the major themes but
you know i guess some of our audience
may be in in university or maybe
encountering situations where they have
to write about these stories and how do
you approach these stories and obviously
the psychoanalytic lens
is a major option to approaching
literature there are other ones many
many other ones obviously but this one
this one stands out with poe because of
you know lacan being who he is and
having written this really important
seminar which he places at the beginning
of his writings a cli
um as the opening chapter so and it's
constantly referred to in a lot of
literature on lacan so it's something
really important to get into
now lacan's interpretation of the text
so is arguably
you know not
an interpretation of the text uh this i
mean this is something that's that i
want to just open up as a question lacan
is he really interpreting this text or
is he to uh use a line from the text
itself is he forcing this into a
procrustean bed
to which he forcibly adapts his designs
as in meaning is he fitting this text
into a preset
you know
you know set of variables and then
those variables the what being you know
the unconscious the symbolic order etc
etc are these variables just taking over
and really the text is just illustrating
something else or is he getting to some
you know what shall we call it truth or
deeper meaning that the text itself
contains that's i mean that's just
that's just something i want to throw
into the air before we get into the
lacan part anyway but uh yeah so what is
la khan doing with this text why is he
interested in it any anyone seems like
he wants to it seems like what he's
trying to do is
use it to demonstrate
essentially like the way the unconscious
and desire functions like a language
functions according to symbolic order
and i think he he makes some claim that
the letter itself is almost like its own
subject in the story
and and and i think he uses the fact
that the content of the letter is never
revealed and in a way he kind of says
the content of the letter doesn't matter
because it's like the symbolic role that
the letter represents
that each character in the story
their position in relation to the
symbolic
meaning of the letter like the symbolic
and not in the sense of like the meaning
behind it but just like how it works as
a as a part of a signifying chain
kind of ends up conditioning the desires
and the the kind of automatic responses
of each of the characters right it's
like it's like either there's a
significance to it so i guess one of the
characters like they think they have it
so their position like they adopt kind
of an automatic uh like position to it
based on kind of it's it's
its place in the symbolic chain i don't
know if if
maybe someone can clarify more and the
word the word automatic there is is well
chosen actually because uh lacan is
actually engaged in a sort of commentary
on um the repetition compulsion which he
actually calls here the like automated
repetition or something like that
it's kind of that
that um
uh that idea where if you suffer a
traumatic event right
in the in the future
you you repeat that event over and over
in your mind again right you have
flashbacks you have dreams or it
manifests as other kinds of neuroses
right it's like you're constantly
reliving the trauma and freud originally
is asking questions about this
saying so what does it say about the
pleasure principle right if everything
we do is driven by the pleasure
principle then clearly reliving events
of the past that are very stressful to
us is not following the pleasure
principle so maybe we have to find
something beyond the pleasure principle
with aka the death drive
which is he goes on in that text beyond
the pleasure principle about the death
the death instinct i think it's better
called um is that is what appears
instead of this and and so lacana's is
doing a kind of extended commentary on
repetition compulsion and the death
drive and for some reason he sees this
text as exemplifying
that
repetition function because the text
sort of nicely divides into a repetition
right the first scene you know you have
the
queen king and the minister and the
minister steals the thing and then in
the second scene you have the the police
the minister and dupe and dupay steals
the letter and then you actually even
have a third repetition at the end that
lacan kind of shoehorns in there i don't
know if it's really legit but there's at
least this double structure of
repetition in the text so he sees this
as somehow exemplifying
something that freud was trying to get
at
that maybe he couldn't quite get at
because lacan has the tools of semiotics
now at his disposal right where he can
refer to the signifier so what is the
signifier doing here
the way that i read this from a lacanian
perspective was actually that this is
kind of a tragic story uh in some
respect because what seems to occur is
the symbolic order of the big other is
disrupted uh by the withdrawal of this
letter which in and of itself has no
content and precisely because it has no
content it can serve as a kind of
ideological point where people invest it
uh as the kind of locus point uh that
holds everything together uh
they're really worried that if it
disappears or if it's used a long way
everything's going to fall apart and at
the end of the story uh the letter is
given back to the person who originally
created it and the kind of harshness or
danger to the symbolic order is
withdrawn and it's stabilized and the
monarchy kind of goes on so i kind of
read it as almost uh
kind of a kind of a mocking uh analysis
of authority from that perspective i'm
not sure if that's the take he makes but
i mean i i always kind of read the the
the point of the purloin letter i mean
it's been a while i i i this is me
revisiting it since i think i've i did
an independent study in my fourth year
undergrad and i remember one of the
essays i read with my professor was the
prolonged leader and maybe the first
ever essay of lacan that i read
and i it's funny i was like i revisited
my notes from from when i wrote that uh
like so i found the word document with
like
my uh like like my thoughts and
reflections on my and my initial fresh
engagement with lacon for the first time
when it was kind of cringe but also like
but also i was like didn't didn't
actually read too bad as bad as maybe i
would have expected it to but i guess
one of the the takeaways i got was sort
of the way
the symbolic function like it leads to a
sort of like determinism i guess i read
like a kind of determinism that like
what a signifier represents in the
signifying change just like determines
our reaction to it and i think he uses
in the text this whole game of like
pluses and minuses as like um an example
of like i guess that evens and odds game
like i think he connects those two
things and like the idea i guess is like
let's say you have a sequence
where it all comes up even or then it's
a mixture
or then it's like odd odd and then even
and it's like each of those sequences
you can then decide to like symbolize as
meaning something
and like by doing that like there's
certain possibilities and things that
can't happen so i think like if you if
you set those rules i'm probably not
explaining it that clearly but like if
you set up some rules where like you
know this number of evens this number of
odds
then like it becomes impossible for a
certain sequence to follow another
sequence because like the rules you've
set up of like what those different
sequences mean kind of determine what's
possible to come next
and i think the idea is that like
because the letter represents
like it has a significance to it that is
it's just like it kind of is going to
lead to a determinism of like the way
people are going to react because what
it represents and not just that but also
like i think even like the role of like
the king and queen like their role their
their signifiers right they mean
something and it's like and that that
determines their reaction to these other
signifiers and in a way it's like the
chain
points to a sort of like predictable
pattern of behavior that is just it
doesn't matter what the actual letter is
but rather its relation to other
signifiers that matters right so it's
like the fact that the signifiers relate
to each other in a certain way what they
actually mean
kind of like at an analog level at a
substantive level it doesn't matter it's
just like what they mean in relation to
each other that then like determines the
series of events and that's kind of like
how he wants to argue our unconscious
functions um yeah that's what i mean i
jesus wrote an essay about the khan's
take on this which is why nobody
actually knows what the content of this
letter is it sometimes implied that it
was about affair as eric said but we
never actually something spicy anyway
something bad enough that people were
invested in it um but it's situated in
this kind of matrix of power where we do
know that the kind of social regime as
exists uh in france in the 1830s by the
way where the monarchy was in
tempestuous straits right so that's also
important uh and so everyone invested
with a great deal of significance even
without knowing what's in it because
they're concerned that it'll bring the
whole administration down right uh and
there's this kind of weird paradox in
the fact that we aren't aware of what's
in the letter but we do know somehow
that it's dangerous so we can't allow it
to get out even though we don't know
what it is and at the end there's this
kind of restoration of the status quo
by taking away the thing that we didn't
actually know the content of but we just
realized it was kind of gap in the
symbolic order that couldn't be allowed
to get out and now everything's smoothed
over so that's jesus take on the cause
take on this story
but
i think that might also yeah i think
that might almost be reading it into
political uh yeah it's way too political
like this is this is much more just a
point about like
signifiers like our unconscious being
determinate by these by like what a role
something plays like it doesn't actually
you're already i think you're already
going too deep
into like the meaning of it rather than
just like
the how is the how is this showing that
like somehow unconsciousness or the
unconscious and signifiers
like determine each other and it's like
you know whether like that i think i
don't know so i think it's it's it's
it's a step
kind of it's a it's a more formal
perspective than like adding the
political content to it or like the
desire content to it that's kind of my
understanding so he's just kind of
saying like this story
emulates the structure of the
unconscious or demonstrates these
structures demonstrates the way
signifiers like determine other
signifying chains together um i don't
know did anyone else have nick can you
uh take us a little further no different
i don't know if you had a chance yeah
i had a look at it yeah and i think what
makes it such a useful story for someone
like lacan is that it it puts the focus
much more on the observer than on the
observed so the other lacanian aspect
here might be you know dupont as a
psychoanalyst and minister of d as the
as his subject the analysis right in
that sense where he there's sort of this
potential possibility of like the the
psychoanalyst never really being able to
sort of you know put away his own
perspective or his own biases and
projections on to the person he's
analyzing or onto the text that he's
trying to read right
and that interesting question more
broadly about interpretation and the way
in which you can never again get to the
actual objective truth of the matter you
never actually know what's in the
purloined letter because you're always
you're very sort of like observation of
the case you're very sort of in
interference with it changes something
about what what you're looking at so i
think that's what makes it so
interesting for lacan to consider as
well and for him to kind of riff on as
well in the way that we've been talking
about
and that does explain the comic effect
in the uh part where they are going
through trying to figure it out right
because even they don't know they don't
know what's in the letter they're
investing it with so much significance
even not being unaware of its content
and they're tearing this hotel down uh
in order to try to find it and that says
more about them than it does actually
about the letter or the exactly exactly
yeah yeah well it says more about them
and it says more about the position that
they're adopting in relation to the
letter as like as kind of signifier and
and and their own uh their own kind of
like position in that matrix
it's a demand it's a it's an attempt to
demonstrate uh like the kind of the
function of these things i can i can
sketch out
one of the broader outlines quickly and
see what you think uh
that'd be good
so
so uh as as you know
you know lacan is taking in the idea of
the sociean sign here which is divided
into two parts the signifier and the
signified so you know the
the signifier in this case will be the
letter and uh the signified would you
know be the meaning of the message
contained in the letter but of course
lacan's
lacan's point with his whole um
bard signified thing is that we you know
we never really get to the signified
what we're really left with is a chain
of signifiers
and that chain of signifiers constitutes
the symbolic you know which which we
enter into at some stage of our
development right so the symbolic is you
know when we acquire language
um
but the general i think outline of this
um is that
you know this chain of signifiers is
determinative for subjectivity right you
are determined
not by you know what you learn in your
life not by
whatever's
innate or natural to being a human
you're determined by the symbolic realm
and this story in a way
demonstrates that because you have this
sort of signifier that goes on this
little adventure this letter
the signifier and of course he plays on
the difference between letter and as in
like the letter of a word and letter as
in like an epistle a message a letter in
an envelope kind of letter
um
to say that you know you
the signifier
goes on this adventure and what it does
is it determines these different subject
positions in relation to it so what you
have in the first
scene is you have the king the queen and
the uh minister right and these three
positions the one who is blind is the
king doesn't know what's going on the
one who sees but thinks they are not
seen this is the queen the second
the second position here and then you
have the third position
the one who sees right the one who kind
of defines what's going on and each of
them sort of corresponds to a different
order right so the first position the
king is the real you know it's blind we
can't talk about it we can't symbolize
the real the second is the imaginary
right the one who sees and imagines
themselves as not being seen
so and then the third one is kind of the
symbolic right the one who can kind of
stand back and take account of this
whole symbolic structure that's at play
and then use it to their advantage
and so then the second scene
happens
and these positions these structures the
sort of structures of these basic
positions stay the same but the
characters occupying them switch right
so
if at first the uh if at first the
minister was in the third position the
one of the the symbolic now in this
second scene where you know he's got the
letter in his apartment and the police
are looking for him and dupan's going to
come and steal it at some point he's in
the second position now he's seeing but
he himself he he imagines himself as not
being seen right which is why when you
know dupan walks into the apartment for
the first time he's uh he's affecting
this this romantic and we right this
almost feminine kind of disposition
which for lacan harkens back to the new
position he's occupying which is the one
of the queen in the first situation
right and then the queen is now in the
sort of first position the one who
cannot see and the police being a kind
of extension of the queen are doing this
looking and they're not seeing anything
right and then dupan is now in the
position of the third which the uh
minister was in in the first scene now
dupayne is in the third position because
he sees what's going on he sees dupay
for what he really is and he knows where
the letter is hidden he sees all these
things and he uh and so that that's what
allows him to uh then you know take
advantage of the situation get the
letter himself and then of course the
khan adds a kind of third
situation because
uh when you're when you do uh get
yourself involved in this sort of chain
of signifiers you you and you end up
getting sucked in right so dupay gets
sucked into the second position he
thinks he's uh seeing and not being seen
he imagines himself as uh very clever
but then the third here becomes the
analyst right that's lacan reading the
story so you have this
this same structure that's repeated
three times as a kind of compulsion of
repetition and each one is determined
each set of subjects
you know the structure of the subjects
remain the same but the the
the characters in each position kind of
shift
between each scene right
so this is what shows you something
about the repetition compulsion right
there's something
in the symbolic there's something about
the way the symbolic works this
constantly you know signifiers don't
refer to signifieds we're going to get
rid of this sort of meaning angle all
they really do is refer to other
signifiers so each displacement
of the signifier
brings out a new kind of um uh the k
brings out a situation where the
characters will occupy another one of
these three basic
subject positions in the story so that's
that's the general sketch of what lacan
is saying anyway sorry it was a bit that
was great that was a great that was a
great summary actually and i think it's
it's it was actually made me feel good
about my undergrad self because i was
like reading i was reading like one of
my little like summaries
uh from that from that um from that uh
that independent study and like
basically i don't know maybe i'll just
pills you can decide whether you want to
keep this in or not but i'm just going
to like read a little bit of it because
i think it adds to everything and kind
of
what you're saying confirms that maybe i
was right when i was this undergrad but
it says basically he is the present
absence as the characters shift
positions on the signifying chain they
essentially take turns being displaced
during the intersubjective repetition
the arrangement is controlled and
decided by the placement of the
signifier the letter along the
signifying chain repetition automatism
is demonstrated by the story through the
interpretation of the way each character
upon acquiring the letter repeats the
other's behavior
the queen right deludes herself on the
secrecy only to have it discovered and
taken
although the minister detected the
queen's secret he similarly hides the
letter in plain view thinking it will
not be found out dupont is able to spot
the letter in the minister's home and
takes it himself as the other two before
him dupont will assure himself of his
secret right as as each character moves
throughout the signifying chain they
repeat the actions of the person before
them all while believing they will
experience a different outcome than the
one already experienced
yeah there you go you you were so much
older than you're younger than that now
that's a great explanation yeah yeah so
yeah it's i think that's where i get the
sort of story i think that's where i
kind of get this idea where i'm kind of
remembering that at the time i think i
kind of was like oh this is like kind of
showing how
like we're a lot more determined uh than
we think we are and to a certain extent
by our actions or somehow trying to show
that
yeah no i should say i think that's a
really great way of explaining the essay
i i am really tempted based upon the way
that you've like expressed things
to actually adopt this kind of political
reading uh of the text and the reason is
i don't know what well the reason is
because i think music is right about the
way that this text should be interpreted
because if you think about the chain of
signification that's going on
and the subject positions occupied one
of the ones that's really important is
the relationship of the queen to this
letter because this letter is invested
with so much labile energy on the part
of all these different subjects because
it comes from the queen but the kind of
irony of all of this
is that the only reason it's invested
with this libidinal energy isn't because
of who the queen is but rather what she
represents she's this kind of sublime
regal figure and the irony is if this
letter gets out and it is what we all
think it is it's going to present her as
a mere human being and take away
this kind of sublimated signification
that she occupies uh because she's just
a person like anyone else she [ __ ]
around on her husband
whatever the case may be whatever the
case might be right so it seems to me
that understanding that uh is really
important because what we have to unders
to see this this story as is an effort
on the part of everyone to keep this d
sublimation from occurring
and therefore
re-ascribing the symbolic order with its
kind of authoritarian significance
because we have the queen appearing as
just a normal person because this letter
gets out
then the whole thing won't be able to
operate anymore that seems plausible to
me that seems plausible to me
well i think it's also true that the
letter clearly like it's its role in the
signifying chain has to be somehow
directly related to the fact
of how it's connected to the signifier
of like regalness i guess in a way right
because like it wouldn't really matter
if it was just some letter
right like like even though we don't
know the signified
we know that it's related to the other
signifier of royalty and i think like
that that whole connection that
interconnection on is what makes it
is what kind of determines the other
reactions on the signifying chain
exactly i think the way to express this
in ejection terms is that the danger of
this letter isn't to the queen uh the
danger of this letter is that it's going
to reveal the fact that the queen is
just a signifier that this particular
person happens to be associated with at
any given time and it might beg the
question of why she's entitled to this
kind of auspicion uh when she's just a
normal person like all of us that's not
to kind of demean her but
it does raise that immediate question
sure and there is kind of a comic
element to this uh where you see all
these extremely intelligent people
racing desperately uh to try to keep
this de-sublimation from occurring uh to
let the cat out of the bag uh if you
want to call it that it's funny that
lacan tries to pretend that he's like in
the in the observer position as the
analyst or something like that that's
also i feel like philosophers just
always love to like make everything in
threes so it's like i don't think he
could stand it being like only like like
a double action he's like i gotta add a
third he's like so i'm gonna adopt the
position
who knows right and that's that's again
the question is it being forced into
this procrustean bed sure
a little bit
and and i yeah i think it's an open
question because i think we do learn
something about the text when we when we
talk about it in this way but we also
learn something and that seems to be the
goal of the seminar is to learn
something about psychoanalysis as well
right because the the unconscious is the
discourse of the other what is what is
that going to mean it's going to mean as
a subject you are eccentric you are
standing outside of yourself he brings
in some of this heidigary and
terminology right you're eccentric you
stand outside of yourself you're not you
know the subject isn't located anywhere
in fact the subject in this
situation is split between three
different subject positions
so
the subject isn't necessarily an
individual when we talk about the
subject it could be divided into many
different kinds of
positions but if you want to remember
the three positions it's really nice you
get we get the politics of the ostriches
right the first one has its head in the
ground can't see anything second one
sees that and is looking at it thinks oh
i can see this one can't see me then
while the second one is thinking that
all satisfied with itself the third one
comes along and uh pecks its ass right
picks uh plucks its rear as as as they
say in the text here so there's the
three positions i'm gonna add a fourth
wrinkle to this uh that kind of builds
on what we were talking about because
there's one fourth person in this kind
of trifecta we have to acknowledge uh
not just the narrator i was gonna say
okay so there's a fourth person the
author himself right uh because poe
himself seems to occupy a weird position
in this chain of significations because
you have a detective whose job is of
course to
re-ascribe the social order uh with this
kind of sublimated quality
but of course you know since we have a
storyteller who's depicting this
occurring
and deflating it in this kind of way
maybe the person who's truly the radical
in this whole process isn't dupe
since he seems to serve almost a
conservative function but the author
who's chronicling this process uh who's
revealing to us uh how artificial uh and
how libidinally invested a lot of this
is so i don't know if we want to get out
of the rule of three uh to use eric's
terminology maybe that's what we have to
do you know there at his rule and
actually say the author occupies an
important role in this kind of well i'm
curious that's interesting i'm curious
to see what litvix says about the
narrator though because it seems like
yeah yeah
just on on poe's role in all of this
it's worth noting as well that he was
sort of pragmatic about these kinds of
stories i mean he actually
was more interested in in his poetry he
recognized that there was a mass market
for these kinds of sort of you know
mystery stories and he was a little bit
more you know like he pragmatic in the
way that he even approached set mark
marketing these things so
it's worth it considering in that sense
but um in terms of the narrator
i'm interested in kind of asking you
guys about the lacanian perspective
there because the conventional reading
is the narrator is either like a
surrogate for the reader or he's somehow
representative of you know america's
relationship with france because dupont
is a frenchman and the narrator is this
sort of like unnamed american who's just
in awe of this european brilliance
but is there any way in which we could
sort of bring him into the arcanian
framework where like i think at one
point lakon mentions that perhaps the
narrator himself is the actual analyst
in all of this and we're looking at this
the wrong way yeah yeah
and i want to say just to make the
sherlock parallel i know that one of us
compared him to watson i think i might
have even done that we maybe a few of us
did and you know he does seem to have
this function where japan kind of smokes
pipe at the end of it and pours himself
a drink and is like you know let me
chronicle my brilliance to you uh except
you know watson is sometimes an engaged
character uh who will actually do things
and has opinions and has a life of his
own that sometimes chronicles the story
stories whereas this narrator really is
a kind of empty vessel into which
deployment
kind of pours uh his opinion and yet the
whole point of the story is that there's
no such thing as an empty vessel right
that any observer inevitably kind of
affects the outcome of what is being
observed so that's i think where the
narrator does kind of occupy a more
interesting place in this kind of tale
than they would in any other more
general story where the narrator serves
an obvious kind of like literary
function but in this case where we're
invited to think so closely about the
role of the observer and the observed we
can't help but kind of wonder if the
narrator doesn't have a greater meaning
in all of this yeah
yeah that's an interesting question i'm
not sure i mean it i could see that the
the narrator somehow being like the
analyst
is an interesting idea but i was also
you know to bring it back quickly i was
looking again at my notes from the
undergrad and it's funny god the
professor that i had at that time was i
loved the way she did seminars like so
she had this thing where you would do
the reading and then she would make you
write basically like
three of them three aspects that were of
most interest in agreement with you or
three aspects and three aspects that
were of most difficulty or disagreement
and then at the very end her last
question which was always very hard
uh is
basically like give a like sum up the
whole principle of the reading in a
couple of sentences
which is i think like a very useful
useful kind of uh and i'm gonna i'm
gonna indulge myself here and read read
what i wrote for the for the for the
like a couple of sentences summing up
the entire seminar of the purlin letter
i mean i don't think it's particularly
good but i basically said in jacques
seminar on the proline letter he uses
the actions of the characters to
demonstrate repetition automatism lacan
achieves this by one showing that
that as each subject acquires the letter
their place in the signifying chain
changes with respect to power power over
others i put in brackets
two demonstrating how each character
will repeat the action of the previous
character that held the position in the
signifying chain ultimately lilikan
wants to suggest that people's behavior
and choices are constituted by and
through the signifying chain of the
symbolic
and their effect on the unconscious
i i think the question that really opens
it up at the end too is is really just
you know lacan's famous last line is
that the
was it the signifier always reaches its
destination right yeah and the idea is
that like is that true right does does
the signifier always
always reach its destination or or is it
an infinite kind of chain of
signification that never stops even when
the analyst gets involved is that the
last word
and so maybe we shouldn't put la cannon
in that third scene as the analyst but
maybe the narrator as the analyst
because that would sort of keep the
signifying chain going we can then
imagine the letter moving on and and
either sort of returning to where it's
supposed to be and then going on another
adventure or continuing on it's sort of
secret
clandestine journey i like that
i like that although i guess i guess the
one difference is that um
because the narrator know like dupin
knows that the narrator knows
right so and that's different than i
think the the other like relationships
right because the whole idea of like
the third position i mean maybe i'm
getting it wrong but is that
they have knowledge that the second
position doesn't have or they the second
position thinks they have
the no the full knowledge but then
there's a third position that has
knowledge that the second position
doesn't know but in this case
the second position knows that the third
position has knowledge right
yeah and i'd like to add like one last
wrinkle to this which is that the real
irony to the story now that i think
about a little bit more and i've heard
what you guys have to say is that uh
despite the fact that a lot of is about
ascertaining uh
the
riddle to this mystery right is that
ultimately the fact that they've
discovered this perlerian letter allows
them to occlude the truth of what
actually happened right uh this isn't
about revealing something to the public
that it needed to know it's about hiding
something that did occur so that this
re-sublimation uh can occur the
signifier finds its destination and in
doing so it once again casts uh this
kind of illusory spell over the symbolic
order which allows us content with it
rather than be critical of it or what i
do like about the whole
way of thinking about it is
emphasizing the way the symbolic chain
is all about different signifiers and
the way that they work in relation to
other signifiers right and it's like
forget about the signified and it's so
it's like
it doesn't actually matter like the only
reason uh the signifier of the letter
matters is because of the s of the way
it's related on the signifying chain to
the signifier of royalty
um and like its position in that cha so
it's like
you know it there's no behind that i
guess in a way it's like there's nothing
behind that other than just these
relations of signifiers and what role
they play and how like their
interactions with each other in in in
the fact it's not about what they are
reference to but how they relate to each
other and it's like there's nothing
behind that is kind of uh the way i
sometimes think about it it's just how
they relate to each other yeah yeah yeah
that's all good
i mean it's the function of the
signifier yes we're focusing on right
and not it's meaning right that's that's
one aspect of it so we don't know what's
in the letter right and the other thing
is that it's hidden in plain sight
so
this letter which people could only read
one side of apparently except for the
queen who knows what's in it but you
know and the other people know what's in
it too right i'm pretty sure the prefect
explains the contents of the letter but
we do not know what's in it because
in a way lecon is saying it doesn't
matter and here's here's a big quote
from heidegger that cinches it um i mean
lacan's quoting heidegger here when when
we're open to hearing the way in which
martin heidegger discloses to us the
word alethea the play of truth we
rediscover a secret to which truth has
always initiated her lovers and through
which they learn that it is in hiding
that she offers herself to them most
truly so you have this kind of secret
element and the truth being out in the
open you know the truth the truth
reveals itself by hiding or gives itself
over by hiding
so that's the play of you know and the
interesting
idea that
if the minister were ever to use this
letter this power that
he has over the queen it would
immediately vanish right
signifiers are kind of spent in the
using of them
and they then then the situation has to
shift again everyone shifts positions
the signifier goes on a new circuit and
that sort of repetitive circuit again is
is sort of this
the essence of this repetition
compulsion is is to be found in this
constant play of signifiers
that are sort of indifferent to their
signifieds
because they hide in the truth and the
truth is kind of hidden in plain sight
but
also secret because we don't know what
it is but we know its functions right we
know we know what's at stake we know who
has power over whom and we know
sort of the general outline of how this
letter is
causing so much trouble in this story
but we just don't know what the [ __ ] it
says
is it a lover is it a is it a some kind
of political incoming incoming invasion
we don't know right we just know that
she's got to hide it and the the father
the law the king right but who must pass
judgment if order is to be restored that
that can't happen because the queen will
be uh you know compromised so what do we
do we keep we keep sort of
shoving the uh signifier along and
that's how you know that's how the
unconscious works in freud's kind of
explanation right condensation and
displacement it takes on energy of other
things and it
and it's displaced it it
is represented by something else so the
you know the the phallus represents the
signifier the signifier represents the
the lack of the mother's phallus all
these different sorts of displacements
and condensations and
the find the the signified is just
[ __ ] it [ __ ] that we don't know what it
means yeah and i think that's sort of
the final take on all of this it's just
like it's it's a really useful metaphor
for textual interpretation basically
right like the text is there in plain
sight the question is how do you
interpret it right like what meaning do
you ascribe to that text so that's i
think what this story is really useful
in terms of getting us to sort of
consider
yeah i like it that's great i think uh
these episodes i mean this is the second
one we've done but i think i mean
this and the bartleby i feel like are
among my favorite ones to do so
hopefully we can do more and have you
back uh lidvik yeah man likewise
likewise hope to be back soon it's a lot
of fun
definitely yeah that would be great
all right and uh i think then we can uh
wrap it up here and say uh say our
goodbyes yeah let's do this again soon
and uh thanks again for joining us
my pleasure indeed
it was an absolute pleasure i love doing
uh i love doing uh some poe with you and
and don't don't forget to raise a glass
for our dearly departed edgar allan poe
or edgar ape
whatever his alternate ego was at one
point perry yeah yeah yeah yeah no
yeah good job all right cool
all right do that
all right everybody it's been fun this
is uh this is
eric uh
taking over the father's position in the
signifying chain for the time being
we'll see where the displacements lead
us all right
[Applause]